look inside
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up guys kid ace here and I'm
backstage at the Kelly Clarkson show
looking for staff members so I can blow
their minds let's go find some people
okay I'm gonna show you one of my
favorite tricks okay but you got to be
down and relaxed all right
put both hands in front of you flat like
a table roll up your sleeves yeah roll
them up keep them flat like a table oh
that's good that's good yeah again keep
them a little bit lower don't move a
little bit forward keep them about right
here make two fists face face them like
this perfect I'm gonna show you my
favorite trick see is one of magicians
onstage they vanish and they reappear
somewhere else but we're gonna do it on
a smaller scale
see I just drew an X on my wristwatch
that X that's gonna represent the
magician all right watch the magician
let's try to get the magician and
disappear puff of smoke puff of smoke
I'm on a budget so I can't afford a fog
machine but look the magician is gone
that's cool else permanent marker that's
why I school to me okay but the coolest
part of the magician always reappear
somewhere else in the room I want you to
say right or left out loud you sure yeah
push your left this toward me drop your
right fist drop it down don't move
follow me go like this look inside is
just crazy I don't know all right we'll
try something else all right it was fun
we made a connection right so I have a
deck of cards you have a deck of cards
you sir what's your name Elliot Elliot
you're gonna select a card when you take
that card I want you to show everyone
here and let the cameras get a good look
at that too okay so take any card you
like right there take a look at it show
everyone here in fact we're gonna take
it a step further Elliot I want you to
go ahead and sign the face of the card
that's what you're gonna do okay is that
cool can you do that give you a sign
sign the face of that card right now cap
the marker put it in your pocket when
you're done
now this gonna be pretty crazy because
Elliot I'm gonna try to heat things up a
bit I'm gonna take your card back I'm
gonna place it facedown in the center of
the packet open your hand hold on to the
deck now you're gonna feel your hands
warm up slightly it's not gonna burn but
you're gonna just feel a little bit of
warm
okay here we go are you ready Eliot here
look you'll fill your hands warm up
slightly just feel a little bit not not
hot but just slightly warm see what's
happened is I'm transferring that heat
from my hands into your hands and it's
penetrating that deck I'll prove it to
you look if I run through the deck take
a look at this if I run through the deck
you'll see that one card and one card
only in the entire deck turns red that's
not the coolest part see it could be any
card
but you Elliott signed a card was your
card the sign seven of Hearts let's go
so hold it here that was fun right so
that will take Elliott sign seven of
Hearts I'm gonna place it in your hand
facedown Elia put your hand on top like
this
yup that hand and block this way here
ooh do this say stop wherever you like
just call out stop stop
do you want to keep going are you happy
here okay no one say it out loud just
memorize the card okay memorize the card
take a look at that car nobody say it
out loud hold out your hand it's gonna
happen to you too now you can't make
this up done see if we run through the
deck check this out one car and one card
only turns red
no I just I think why did you what did
what do you remember the cards you had
what was it two of diamonds and you're
holding on the sign seven of hearts
right that one was for you you look like
you're having a good time
what's your name Becky all right Becky
you want to try one more thing out you
and I you want to have some fun okay so
we take your index finger like this hold
it up in the air and I want you to touch
a car gently touch one take it out you
sure you can change your mind right now
all right take it out show everyone here
now here's what's gonna happen I'm gonna
take your car back but you are gonna say
stop wherever you want to place your
card say stop whatever you like place
your card facedown I'm gonna take
Becky's card I'm gonna place it in the
deck I'm gonna give it a cut I'm gonna
give it a few more cuts and I'm gonna
give it a shuffle for good measure all
right now look Becky any number you want
between 20 and 40 there are 52 cards in
a deck but let's keep it in the mid
range between 20 and 40 shout that
number out right now
why 37 okay I'll try to do this with one
hand with one hand with one hand I'm
gonna cut that should be 37 I'm gonna
complete that cut the 37th card right
here shoots out of the deck what was
your card
and you can keep that thank you guys
that was a lot of fun guys I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not going to stop
yep still here not going anywhere I see
you don't walk away from this